for the miami heat trying to close out
the bucks
33-18 they outscore them and lead it
52-46
i bet you don't know who that is hey
that's the boss rick ross
american express halftime report ernie
johnson with kenny at chuck and shaq
thanks my buddy you're a good guy uh
exactly because it's
average players who's special great
player uh
happy i could help you scott i got a big
assist from
dr mike from shaq on that one
we're coming back in a second
[Music]
[Laughter]
that'd be close if i if i were a cat
person but i am not a cat
you don't like cats honey allergic to
him shaq
[Music]
if you're out there playing free
basketball by yourself step up for your
brother tonight
defense me fence first of all you're
wrong
i'm not wrong shaq they got 73 points
they're on poster they don't pay for 140
bro i don't care how many points you got
as long as you win the game y'all
everybody got to step up but first of
all
first of all i speak from not being a
great defensive player but having
championship
experience i know what the hell i'm
talking about the other's got to step up
period i don't give a damn what you're
talking about hey listen listen rob hook
me up rob hey listen let me tell you
look me up rob
big shot bob i appreciate you bishop
roberto doria jason
uh james posey don't forget when i got
double triple things
don't get caught away carrying your fat
ass
listen they got to play some defense
like he said they
gave up 70 points to a team that's
missing rob hook me up probably is five
four five best players hey ernie a
friend of mine tracy asked me a question
who's tracy tracy uh her dad coaches
saint joe's jim boyle one of the great
man i've ever met in my life
uh people can can can she wanted to know
because she's nosy
uh can they the players they can't see
those
people in the stands can they no they're
merchants yeah they see the same they
see this gummy
but they see faces they see everything
the same thing i was just asking maybe
they were super imposing for the people
at home
it's like it's like in baseball you know
you can look in the stands but not see
anything when they have those
all those fans in the stands educational
people see those okay have you ever been
on a package
that's a dumb question it is a dumb
question have you ever been on a
conference call in the last since the
pandemic had started
what do you mean a zoom call a comcast
call yeah but i'm talking you know like
shacks in the stands dude they only see
that at home with my question
they see the screen okay thank you ernie
okay they actually say
don't try to embarrass me don't call me
dumb on television
[Laughter]
hey listen we were just first of all
y'all need to stop it
i never had it man i never started
haters i would sit here
you're the one who started it
contribution goes more than the stat
sheet
triple single so
you started i never said that i never
i've never had
any kind of beef and you started to beef
and i
didn't do this i've seen triple single
on my instagram too many times
way too many times of what you've seen
from the phoenix suns a team that you
see a lot playing out there on
on the west coast and obviously devin
booker everybody knows him but this is a
team that's going down there and
and gone four and oh so far it's great
to see book playing well and phoenix
playing well but get my man
out of phoenix it's not good for him
it's not good for his career
sorry chuck but uh wow they got to get
booked out of phoenix i need my man to
go somewhere where he can play great
basketball
all the time and win because he's that
type of player are you tampering
maybe he's not a great shooter he's a
great defender
but you have to honor yourself with
kimber and that opens up things for
haywood
brown and tatum when you have a player
out there
who's who can't shoot or who's not a
great shooter teams know you can cheat
off of that guy
and that's going to make it harder on
those guys if kimball's not there
we know huh throwing shots
taking shots at me no no no no no
come on man what are you talking about i
thought the same thing when i heard it
oh that sounds like
i thought the same thing we're talking
about marcus smart uh it's hey
you said guys sounds sound very similar
to draymond green
all right now you know what kenny are
you going
there may be a little crack in here
great dude not let kenny come between us
i'm telling you
i heard the same thing see now you're
searching kenny my eyebrow went up just
like his hero
d way got that studio 54 looked oh man
on camera right now open it up big dog
[Music]
[Music]
inspiration started earlier tonight
during the pregame show i want you to
take a look
at your look versus your good buddies
look
dwayne wade tonight tried to copy your
look and go
with the open shirt
no comment no comment no comment is it
is a retired player allowed to have that
look um
he needs to be outdoors right now i'll
tell you that a little you need a little
breeze going on man it's a little sweaty
inside that uh inside
inside that studio but uh man d-wade's
crazy y'all y'all crazy in that studio
the laker nation why listen why are you
people so excited it's still 1-1
i know but they just want to get at you
they just want to get me hey listen i'm
sticking with my pick
hey dame rub some icy hot
on the shack right on the uh ain't no
shack right who was that from
laker nation my laker nation okay well
if the laker nation has
a distinguished gentleman to do
something i got to do it
why you got to put your mask on got to
fix it apparently he's going to stand up
and walk away look good yeah you're good
yeah look good we don't see your face oh
that's not even the broom if you break
that one shaquille yeah i'll tell you
man that's not even
the cheap proof
hey y'all all excited y'all won a game
hey
don't you ever disrespect liquor nation
you understand me i got you like a
nation
always hey hey he goes for real wait
y'all all sisters y'all
sent to this it's 1-1 don't matter
hey hey look this is on camera four damn
lillard
rubble little zorbine junior put
something about
junior is not going to help at this
location well listen that's more of a
muscle
all black people know if you put duct
tape on something it holds it together
yeah that's how we put our furnace
together in the hood but they put some
duct tape on it
and you're good to go dame i need three
more wins brother
why you always switch up late though you
said the lakers are getting swept
oh no i know it's still clear
we know it's 1-1 and now it's going to
be a good sir but you're words
actually nowhere when you when you come
to words
when you come out and say it's going to
be a sweep you got to expect come on
back i got your leg relationship
uh i handled my haze and even chuckled
and four out of six dude i got hazed my
dog
my moses maurice cheeks andrew tony you
know it's crazy i never got haste what
was
what was the most uh bizarre thing they
made you do
uh take andrew tony warm milk like 11
o'clock in the morning milk
how did you find warm milk first of all
i had to go to room service
oh my god and uh dr j wanted a newspaper
first thing in the morning
and it used to always piss me off
because i like well i got to get up
early and get you a newspaper
so look the first day the first day i
got this scotty's guy was like get my
bag rook i was like
i don't do that i'm the franchise player
and i never got aced
you you [ __ ] been a joy to be here i
show up
you're like getting my balance like bro
this is my team bro
i had to carry people i had like four or
five back walking through the aisle
my hazing wasn't a bad hazard yeah for
real my hazing was actually yeah
right charles barkley carried luggage
you're supposed to get that i ain't
doing
congratulations uh how does it feel
you got it confused did you understand
my greek brother
no yeah uh i did a little bit
the first part of it okay hold on sink
there
is that correct uh he said
congratulations but i i don't even
understand
one word you got right all right anyway
how does it feel coming from where you
come from to greece to you know have all
these honors to be one of the top
players in the game i could tell that
you're happy and you're emotional about
this war but
i know this look you have to look in
your eye that that this award is good
but this is not the ultimate award
so you know how does it feel coming from
where you come from
uh it feels great uh when i when i got
to the league i was 18 years old
you know people believed in me i
believed in myself and i know the only
way to achieve
a word like this is work hard each day
um
you know when you put your mind into
something usually comes through and
when you you know you your action lead
towards that
usually comes uh to reality uh but at
the end of the day we got to keep you
know working hard
as a team so we can as you say we can
get the big trophy
but you know it takes day by day as long
as we're together as long as we play
hard as long as we go out there have fun
compete
good things gonna happen for this team
there's it's a weatherman from channel 4
in the uk
uh oh you could just i don't know l.a
you want to hear it one time and then
try it okay let's let's let's look to
liam dutton's that was pretty good
though but in the sunshine in northwest
wales at raf mona
just up the road from clan by the
porsche queensland
that was awful would you like to have
another that was awesome would you like
to have another crack at it if you could
have knocked out that's not going to
read it again
freeze back up there for the man there
you go
hey seriously though can we hear it
pronounce it again i want to yeah you
want to hear it again i do
for real all right let's hear it i'm
standing by the push wings go get it
when drove us and silly
go go
first of all if you live that place you
got to potentially get that changed
yeah that's just stupid there it is yeah
listen
does it say robin williams in there it
does
yeah rob will almost groceries
you could probably you could probably
find a lot of different words
don't go gadget yeah anyway that was uh
i'm sure you at home found that as
entertaining as we did you could not
pronounce that until you were an adult
look can you diabetes
well that's where they sell your shack
soda oh shack soda's done
[Laughter]
what is that all right that's a dog man
that's a rat man that's a dog
man and and i believe that's a wrap for
inside the nba
gracias police
oh that's just copyright 20. good try
shaq that was it was close